ah che bello mi sembra di guardare una
uomini e donne
qual è l'uomo dei due belle a tutti i
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video sono
fa vigenti ci siamo tornati su e vi è
che praticamente ha fatto un nuovo
personaggio chiamano così che sarebbe
poi bot
questo qua che sarebbe la versione
maschile di heavy e non so che cosa
cambia parte il fatto che abbia un pene
però si spera che abbia un penny
marshall zio come stai
voglio capire un attimo se che cosa
cambia dalla prima kiss kiss
hai una voce che mi farà pare come pochi
acer e frate io sono farisei e tu chi
sei cristiano in maschi steve a cazzo
piace il riso a mancarmi tutti fermi
scusa ma se 6 samantha dopo l'operazione
perché si gioca i pieni da solo nomi da
uomo e se gioco con lui mi dandomi la
donna che cazzo di problemi a una
pesante l'operazione l'hai fatta proprio
si disputa chiamerà queste pugliese
reagan cioè space ma che cazzo dici
palma con le parole
scusami se io non volevo offendere io
sono fa vigenti come ti chiami nomi da
maschio per cortesia almeno quello
associato con un uomo che non si chiami
giovanna oppure che ne so cioè le sa
quanto ti senti donna oggi
chiariamo subito queste cose vuoi essere
la il mio fidanzato
ascolta io sono un uomo quindi non
possiamo comunque mi chiamo lorenzo
piacere di rum e canzoni ma guarda se
vuoi proviamo essa la mia fidanzata
ma lui non sa
sono un uomo sono un uomo
se dunque llodra
sono un uomo e quindi non possiamo
comunque mi chiamo lorenzo e tanto
piacere
basta che non me lo metti nel sedere
aiutaci tu non sai di avere ragione se
facciamo un duetto ci stai qualcosa
potrà uscire fuori da sta roba che in
quel coso di serio
devo dirti qualcosa di serio non so che
cazzo vuol 10 dovresti cantare in teoria
sai presente cantare e mi qualcosa di
rock ma ti droghi sono tutto bagnati no
che si va a finire in cose che ascolta
ziona o più quanto più amo lo sapevo io
sto scansource calmo calmo molto calmo
tranquillo solo amici noi due non ti
fare strani ma bp lontano molto lontano
magari abita al piano di sotto e però
non si sa mai diciamo così che poi non
ho capito ancora un po sul pianoro non
può suonare in che senso
ma tu la conosci e via perché magari non
lui non sa che esiste l'esemplare
femminile ma lo sapevo che inzuppa il
biscotto sporca ciardo farti un test
devo dimostrare di essere umana ok umano
ha innanzitutto sei un maschio quindi
chiariamo un test per dimostrare di
essere umano che cosa può essere un ma
quando tocchi le zinne e viarie ct sta
strozzando
bella a tutti i ragazzi
devi saper continuare bella tutti i
ragazzi perché se ne va giuro che mi sta
andando zio giuro i benvenuti in questo
nuovo video
ok io non sono un road trip to bergamo
io non sono robot lurido babbano tutti
ragazzi è pervenuti a questo video non
sono un robot lurido babbano si potrebbe
anche andare conosci fa vj vero zio uno
script ma quando mi sveglio la mattina
potrebbe anche essere non lo so qual è
il tuo video preferito di fa vj set
maggio il tuo e va beh guarda anche il
mio quale canzone che altri aiuti campo
si è mica un jukebox boy friend di
justin bieber
ecco vediamo se sei all'altezza di
justin bieber amico ma io chiamo
bruxelles chiostri beep beep scusi mi
scusi non volevo offenderlo adesso
cambia molto bene una di michael jackson
dai che maicon lo sconti non puoi non
ascoltare michael per me è se la zia
come stai bene figliole to bene figlio
allarghiamo qua figliolo solo per cambia
bombato non ci allarghiamo ascolta devo
farti una domanda tu conosci boy bot
per me non è stato bello però è perché
c'è la picco perché mia mamma è come un
vigile a ho capito quindi non potete
bombare perché sono tua madre schiaffi
in faccia ho capito allora ragazzi
possiamo alla domanda seria che l'avevo
fatta tempo fa però non mi avevano
risposto decentemente
magari lui riesce conosci air games per
capire se si è bello perfetto dalle se
ci faccio la domanda trabocchetto con il
tuo personaggio preferito
dammi soddisfazione almeno tu almeno tuo
amico mio da mirko il pubblico scritta
bravissimo mi chiamavo chiesta cleverbot
mi ha risposto bull ma va chiesta di via
mi ha risposto steve di happy meal ci
credo che ci ha azzeccato bravissimo
finalmente un discorso serio e una
persona che ne capisce il mio e bull ma
no ma io da coop si ma mangia le forbici
e una sotto forma di sadismo 10th quale
senza di più la mia piccola non ha senso
ecco ragazzini che possono chiudere qui
l'episodio è stata alquanto strano
parlare con un robot donna uomo drag
queen qualsiasi cosa sia quindi
ragazzini che possono più dell'episodio
proviamo a concluderlo insieme a lui
vedere che risponde fini ragazzi servito
è piaciuto lasciate commento e mi piace
anche alla pagina che sei dimenticata
del ragazzi ho capito aspetta un attimo
cazzo pagina di facebook e comuni video
tratte una descrizione e non siete
ancora iscritti
se non siete ancora iscritti scrivibili
perfetto e noi ci rivediamo in un
prossimo video della ragazzi ecco così
si fa e che cazzo